between Ral's just big boned. Okay,
Mal's big boned. Guys, they're being
mean. So, actually, you don't need to
reply to any of the points where they
clearly prove that you're lying for your
own personal gain. He wouldn't do it
now. Okay, hopefully. We hope. I don't
think. But he did do it once when he was
20 or 21.
>> Like, it's almost physically impossible
for me to do anything. Like, that's not
that's not possible.
>> Hope hopefully we're all following
Fish's train of thought here. So,
yesterday put out this video on short
fatu. Okay, short fataku dev. Uh, we're
going to take a look at this first, but
really we're here for the food shops
reaction to this video. It's quite
funny. Did not have very good defenses.
I'm going to be real though. It's food
shops, so what do you expect? So, let's
take a look at the morale shortaku video
first. Short Fight Otaku, despite the
rancid, self-deprecating name, is a
political and philosophical content
creator. Going by dev, he struggles to
gain any sense of notoriety as of
recent, failing to at least get 10,000
views despite having over 140,000
subscribers. These numbers are dwindling
as well, but he still keeps chugging
along. Maybe if he put this much,
>> very hateful video. very handy to
literally anything else he wouldn't be
an ugly fat disgusting lying piece of On
the 26th of April Hassan and Ben Shapiro
have a little spat on Twitter and as you
would expect from a degenerate
bottomfeeding scum Dev decides to try
and do an epic own on Hassan claiming
that the recent Trump shooter was
actually a Hassan fan. Does Dev show any
evidence for this? No, not at all. In
fact, the shooter was actually
>> So yeah, just no idea why he even
claimed this. Totally [__]
>> Retweeting critiques of Hassan and
disagreed with him politically. Hassan
points this out and instead of taking
the L, Dev says, "Step up to debate or
step off." What? You just lied about an
attempted presidential assassin being a
Hassan fan got proven wrong and your
response is debate me, bro. I'm sorry,
Dev. What would the debate be about
exactly? There is zero evidence for your
claim and plausible evidence for
Hassan's defense. You idiot. But hey,
just so you know, I'm not compromised.
Hassan shocked his dog.
>> And you know, Dev wouldn't debate Hassan
himself either. You know, Dev would
never debate Hassan himself on that
topic. If someone's like, "Sure, let's
debate about whether that shoot was one
of my fans or not." He'd be like, "Why
don't you debate Destiny instead? Why
don't you debate Destiny?"
>> Again, as an empath, that truly affects
me. Let me introduce you to performative
activism. Hassan is bad. So nobody's
really going to care if you lie about
him. Dev gains social capital by lying
about Hassan, claiming that the recent
Trump shooter was a Hassan fan. Instead
of arguing in the replies for his
position, he does a quote retweet battle
where he substantiates nothing. The goal
here isn't to prove that Hassan is
wrong, or more specifically that Hassan
does harmful content that creates
politically violent people. The goal
here is to look like you're a genius
debater who owned Hassan on Twitter. You
look smart to the drooling DGG [__]
guzzlers. you've aligned yourself with.
But this proves nothing. Ultimately, you
lied about Hassan and you will never
take accountability for this lie or the
several others I will point out in this
video. Because with a dying YouTube
channel and nothing really going for
you, what more can you really do while
you sit on your lard ass all day playing
pedophile slop games? Really pushing
boundaries with the
>> There are some comments on this video
going, "How is Pragmat a pedophile game?
How's Pragmat a pedophile? Why'd you
call Pragmat a pedophile slop?" 13 live
concurrent fatty the step up in debate.
What more can you really do while you
sit on your lard ass all day playing
pedophile slop games? Really pushing
boundaries with the 13 live concurrent
fatty. The step up in debate line Dev so
proudly shouts is also extremely
pathetic given he is constantly ran from
Jtock, a streamer who is opposed to
Destiny. This is important because
instead of debating JTO, talking to him
directly, or DMing him, he would rather
gossip in Destiny's offline chat about
him. Jtock tags him in his server to
confront him for lying and Dev doesn't
respond. Dev makes a claim about Pixie
using the court system in bad faith.
Says he was proven right and yet again
Juck confronts him and he doesn't
respond. Dev is extremely willing to
make claims about people without
substantiation. He will say Pixie is an
evil succubus [__] but will never
explain himself. This results in Dev
constantly virtue signaling, doing
performative activism, and running
constantly from
>> So, so he he was like, you know, talking
some [__] about Pixie and then not
backing it up on Twitter. Basically was
like, I've got the evidence. I'll have
to look for it. And he was like, yeah, I
just have to look for it. People kept
pressing him. I have to look for it.
Press him in DMs. Yeah, I haven't had a
chance to look for it yet. I'll look for
it.
>> Debates all while criticizing Hassan for
doing the same exact thing. What if I
told you Dev actually had a pattern of
lying though, and this wasn't just the
one instance with Assan? Let's start
small. Someone asks Dev if he's okay
with pedophiles in his community. Dev
says, "No, that's why I banned you." In
contrast, here's a clip of Dev saying he
feels bad about banning pedophiles in
his community as long as they're not
preying on children in his Discord.
>> If I knew for sure that someone on my
server was trying to ddle kids, then I'd
ban them like 100%. Yeah, but like off
your server though. Hey Dev, what's up?
Hey, holder. What's up? Like, if none of
it was happening in your spaces, it just
>> I I just feel so bad kicking out the
pedophiles when it's not my
>> I don't know. It feels It feels wrong to
me. On Twitter, I make a reference to
Lilith. Love it.
>> Okay, so I just want to say something
about that quickly. Um, it's weirder to
say, and this will be relevant later.
It's actually weirder to say it feels
bad than it is to say you don't like
doing it on a technicality. Do you know
what I mean? It's like if if you had a
thing where it's like I never want to
have to look into I never want to give
an inch on offplatform stuff because I
never want to have any responsibility to
go and look into [__] that's not
happening on platforms I control simply
the moment I start if I start doing that
for one thing I have to do it for
another and another and another and I
never want to even start doing that.
That's one thing. Even with, you know,
when it comes to actual active
predators, I feel like generally most
people will let that rule slip and just
be like, "Okay, [__] I'm just going to
ban these I'm just going to ban this
[__] freak anyway, cuz [__] this is
literally not even worth, you know,
having around for some principled rule."
That's how most people generally will
act, I think. Um, it's actually weirder
to say, uh, oh, you know, it just feels
wrong doing it. It just feels wrong
saying you feel bad about it. Why do you
feel bad about it? Why do you feel What
do you mean you feel bad about it?
That's actually weirder to say like
almost anything else.
>> But being a fan of Shadman, Dev
criticizes me for saying I came without
evidence. This is funny considering he
had no evidence for the Assan shooter
thing. But sure, let me substantiate my
claim. Unlike you, in 2018, Lilith Love
did a cosplay of Shadman. This was after
Shadman sexualized real children with
Daphne Keen, Keemstar's daughter, and
Lieutenant Corbus. Lilith Lovevet also
promoted the same DIY HRT website as
Keffles. The same one with the lolliccon
packaging. The same one that was
criticized for
>> Dude, Ethan Ralph just replied to a
moral tweet about SFO
>> attempting to circumvent parents in
order to give children hormone
replacement therapy. Dev is also friends
with food shops who claim to have POCD
so severe they had to cross the street
in order to avoid spontaneous child
abuse.
>> Like for example, I wouldn't even walk
on the same side of the street as a kid.
Like in real life just because I had
POCD. I was definitely scared of kids.
Yeah. I was just like incredibly
definitely scared of kids in general
because I would be so scared that I was
like a real pedophile that I would
convince myself that I was a monster
that even being like even breathing like
the same air as children would be like
viol like be a violation. Food shops
would attempt to show emails to justify
their therapist supposedly prescribing
lolliccon pornography as an answer to
this troubling problem. The email had
nothing about Loi or POCD included.
Later, food shops admitted that Loi was
>> Yeah, this PCD story is totally
incoherent. Anyone who pushes it is
either so [__] they belong on
disability or lying. Now, SFO claims he
authentically believed it.
>> Only briefly mentioned.
>> So, you've been to therapy for the PCD
thing. Uh, and you consume lolly
separately. So, have you have you ever
told
>> I went to
>> I I went to therapy for OCD in general?
Sure. Yeah. So, have you ever have you
does your the the lolly consumption?
Does that come up in your therapy
sessions? You don't have to tell me, but
>> uh it came up in one session only and
only as a side tangent.
>> Food shops lied about being prescribed
lolliccon porn to attempt to justify
consumption and even views loi as drawn
child pornography.
>> Yes, I consume lollycon. Okay. Yes, I
recognize it is drawn child pornography.
Okay. Devils say food shops isn't a
pedophile, but really, let's just hear
it from food shops themselves.
>> Let's say you're a pedophile and you're
trying to hold yourself off with
lollycon lolly, right? To try and like
hold yourself off so you don't.
>> I am a pedophile. I like femininity.
>> But do you like it more or less than
like masculinity?
>> I want a cute little girl that I can
wrap my arms around. So there's all
these and there's also food shops saying
that because she's sexually interested
in Lolly, she would accept that as a
quote unquote small P pedophile as in
colloquially it's kind of you're kind of
a pedophile because you're attracted to
children. You're attracted to children
in some form. It may not be a clinical
primary exclusive attraction to actual
real life prepubescent minors. However,
it is an attraction to children.
Therefore, it is colloquially
pedophilic. So, she is a small P
pedophile and has made that point
herself and said it selfidentified. So,
well, you know, if you're bar is
actually, oh, that have to be a clinical
pedophile for me to care, then sure,
food shops may still not meet that. But
the idea that you're pushing the POCD
[__] is [__] crazy.
>> More or less than like masculinity. I
want a cute little girl that I can wrap
my arms around. I need to I need to have
a little girl to wrap myself around. I
need to have like a 12-year-old.
>> It's hard to take Devon his word when he
is so obviously psychosexually
compromised at the sight of a borderline
crossdresser. Really taking in the
pre-transition photos as he went along.
His wife even caught on to this, making
fun of him for chasing mid-trans hole on
Twitter.
>> Oh man. So,
>> I got a private message of Scrumps. He
was talking to other people. It was like
leaked to me. Okay.
>> A few months ago.
>> Okay. He was He's now saying that
apparently I was like in love with
Lilith and I was pining over her while
he was [__] her the whole time.
Like completely [__] delusional
[__]
>> right?
>> She's cute, but no, I was never
interested because I'm not like a
[__] [__] s.
>> Uhhuh.
>> [__] true. You flirted.
Oh,
>> really?
Okay. Got to do this without getting
swallowed. Anyway,
>> it was it was ridiculous. Commencing
guidance protocol. Their eyes have
pining. Definitely not.
>> Want wanted a good digging down from?
Yes.
>> No.
Can
>> I just not have any honest real
conversation with you anymore because
you're like this right now.
>> Listen. Listen. I'm on your side. I'm
still SAYING
>> WHAT THE [__] DON'T GET SWALLOWED.
>> Can you restart?
>> I don't know how restart.
>> I don't know. I'm asking if you can.
>> Don't know.
>> Okay. Not like actual flirting, just
like casual just being like like [__]
Twitter flirt. You [__] say you'll
[__] traps on Twitter all the time.
>> It's not flirting. It's goofing around.
Flirting mean Okay. For it to be an
actual flirt and not just a joke, there
has to be real intent behind it.
>> Chat, I need a poll. I need a poll about
>> no garden this year. Astro
>> about whether or not telling a woman
you'd [__] her on Twitter counts as
flirting.
>> Identifying commencing.
>> Intent is a part of flirting.
>> Their eyes have long since.
>> I'm not cheating. I'm just goofing
around.
>> It's not cheating though.
>> Dev framing his relationship with Lilith
as normal is a bit dishonest. He was
really interested in this trans baddie.
So much so that he would go on to her
Kiwi Farms thread and start defending
her from a logs. Not well, mind you, a
lot of the messages are just gross
sexual comments. Uh, but an attempt was
made nonetheless. Dev also lied in my
little Twitter spat with him, doing yet
another quote retweet, which I'm sure
makes him feel super badass, saying how
he doesn't pay attention to my part of
the internet, implying he never saw
JTO's offer to debate. This is such an
obvious lie. I don't know why he even
typed this out. I have personally seen
short photaku in Quean's chat. He has
called into Turkey Tom streams. He made
a video about Chugga Conroy. He calls
into Wick streams frequently. You engage
with Destiny. You go into his offline
chat and [__] talk Jtock when you're too
scared to say it to his face. So much
for those [__] safe spaces you
constantly complain about. By the way,
in January, Dev tweets out saying, "I
actively killed my own channel rather
than sell out to MAGA. I have zero
regrets." This frames Dev as being a
principled individual, one unwilling to
sacrifice his values for things like
money or social influence. Dev lied
about Hassan, and when he was proven
wrong, he refused to engage. Dev ran
from debating Jtock and lied saying he
doesn't pay attention to the space he
himself is in as justification. Dev has
a history of saying doxing is bad. They
stalk, they dox, and they're not above
IRL harassment, including 4chan prank
[__] like ordering a bunch of pizzas and
taxi cabs to someone's house.
>> Yet, he participates in communities
where doxing is not only done but
justified and celebrated. Short fat
otaku is a coward, a liar, an
unprincipled loser, grasping desperately
for any sense of relevancy by epically
quote tweeting Hassan despite very
clearly being in the wrong. But hey,
Hassan is bad, so it's all justified. I
guess the entire point of principles is
that they work for people you don't like
or even your enemies. Dev is compromised
and will lie about people he doesn't
like to defame them and will lie about
people he does like to try to make them
seem less bad than they actually are.
Dev is the very thing he rants about in
his videos and complains about on
Twitter. There is way more I could put
in here like him trying to defend
himself on his own Kiwi Farms thread and
looking like a total [__] loser, but
I'm sure you get the point. I doubt Dev
will ever respond substantially to any
criticism, let alone mine. And
ultimately, I think that's fine. It
probably wouldn't break 10,000 views
anyways.
>> So, I think Dev has actually responded
to criticism before. I think he went on
sidescrollers and fought with them over
the January 6 stuff, but he'll never do
it when he's wrong. A great Doom Media
video there, guys. Great great video
from Doom Media, my favorite YouTuber.
Go and check out the Doom Media video
there, guys. Go and support it. Go and
hype it. Hyping's important, guys. Now,
as I mentioned, food shops reacted to
this and it went [__] terribly. What
did food shops have to say in defense of
SFO? Let's take a look.
>> It says fat lying chaser and morb
weed. Thank you.
>> So, this person has a crush on me and
because he cannot get on me u because he
cannot get to me. Um I think uh I think
he now has a vendetta because uh you
know he cannot get to me. All right. Uh
441 views. Okay. So far four hours ago.
Not bad. I hate shout. All right. Let's
take a look. Fat L.
>> Uhoh. So, this is actually a prepared
video, it seems. So, look.
>> Shadow Taku, despite the rancid,
self-deprecating name, is a political
and philosophical content creator. Going
by dev, he struggles to gain any sense
of notoriety as of recent, failing to at
least get 10,000 views to move your calm
down. Struggling. Don't get me wrong, we
love the coal. Keep feeding us.
>> Steam locomotive emoji. Steam locomotive
emoji.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> He struggles to gain any sense of
notoriety as of recent, failing to at
least get 10,000 views to
>> uh he is struggling career-wise, but in
terms of notoriety, I'm not sure if he's
short on that. I don't I don't think
he's short on notoriety. I think when it
comes to notoriety, he has plenty of
that. Um Yeah. Yeah. Like I I think I
think he has plenty of notoriety. It's
just
>> No, he doesn't.
>> People don't really give a [__] That's
why no one's watching. It's just that uh
you know he his uh his videos have been
struggling. So I understand
>> despite having over 140
>> he's got notoriety like anyone who's
fallen off has notoriety. They're kind
of used to
>> Oh yeah. Um Oh yeah. A little bit of a
lore. Okay. So moral live the person who
made this video is the original person
who said this. Okay. About me.
>> Listen. I'd be lying if there wasn't an
M2F that I wouldn't go crazy style on.
>> Yep. That's him. Yep. Same person who
made this video.
>> Subscriber.
>> Yep. That's talking about me. These
numbers are dwindling as well, but he's
still chugging along.
>> Maybe if he put this much effort into
literally anything else, he wouldn't be
an ugly, fat, disgusting, lying piece of
[__] On the 26th of April, Hassan,
>> this is some like reverse flash.
>> Yeah, is down bad. What's the problem?
Facts. Facts.
>> Levels of hatred.
>> This is This is some Lex Luthther Batman
levels of hatred, dude. Okay,
>> this is some this is some Batman against
Superman levels of
>> Ben Shapiro have a little spat on
Twitter and as you would expect from a
degenerate body down good or something
to try and
>> what the [__] Wait, also
>> Alex Luther Batman dude. This chick
literally got no idea what's going on at
any point. It's crazy, man.
>> So, not only that, like why call Dev a
chaser when you yourself is a chaser? I
don't I I don't I don't understand the
logic there. Like you're you're calling
him the same exact thing that you
probably are. Also, I'm pretty sure Mau
is also fat.
I'm pretty sure
>> aren't you a fat chaser, too?
>> Own on Hassan, claiming that the recent
Trump shooter was actually a Hassan fan.
Does Dev show any evidence for this?
>> No, not at all. In fact, the shooter was
actually retweeting.
>> Oh, that's selfhatred on part of uh on
part of Dev, by the way. Okay.
>> Moral's just big boned. Okay. Moral's
big boned.
>> I do think that is an L on a part of
death. I I think I
>> fat cats are endearing. Okay. Fat cats
are endearing.
>> Shooter. The the shooter is not a Hassan
ban. It's pretty clear that the shooter
was like a liberal, right?
>> Critiques of Hassan and disagreed with
him politically. Hassan points this out
and instead of taking the L, Dev says
step up to debate or step off. What you
>> I mean at least he is willing to debate.
Like I feel like whenever somebody gets
hauled up into one of these like
positions, I feel like they just never
want to debate about it. But
>> it's funny though about an attempted
assassin.
>> I mean, I do think he's wrong.
>> Being a Hassan fan got proven wrong and
your response is debate me, bro. I'm
sorry, Dev. What would the debate be
about exactly? There is zero evidence
for your claim and plausible evidence
for Hassan's defense, you [__] idiot.
But hey, just so you know, I'm not
compromised. Hassan shocked his dog and
as an empath that truly affects me. Let
me introduce you to performative
activism.
>> Well, dude, I think this is too much
energy, bro. What did Dude, did Dev [__]
your transgirlfriend or like
>> like, dude, I feel like Do I even need
to play it? This is too much energy.
This is too much energy. Where's the
[__] clip, man?
>> Your What is What is is your appeal? How
at the end of the day, we have guns,
right? is unabonga cring and tower
operators. UNABONGA AUTOMOTIVE body
repairs. UNABONGA MISS MISCELLANEOUS
VEHICLE EQUIPMENT. UNABONGA. OH MY GOD.
OH, DESTROYED. HOLY [__] DUDE. HOLY
[__]
SORRY. Hold on. Sorry. I you you you got
you got obliterated. So So I I just had
to do that. I'm sorry.
>> So So which of those two groups do you
think
>> Sorry. Yeah. Is it moral's bringing too
much energy? Okay, food chops. Okay,
food chops. Uh, forgive me if I
disregard your advice on how much energy
people should bring situations. Forgive
me. Forgive me if I think you may not be
best positioned to evaluate.
>> Oh, what did dev do? What did dev do to
you, man? Did Did Oh,
>> dude, this is something I hate as well.
What? Oh, what did I do to you? What did
they do to you? Someone did this to me
in DMs when I was annoyed at them and
they they they were like, "What? Oh,
what? I've been good to you. I've been
good to you, have I?" It's like, "It's
not about whether you've been good to
me. It's about what you've done to me,
okay? It's never about what you [__]
done to me, okay? Frankly, if it's
against me, I'll probably care less.
It's about how you're acting in public.
It's about the fact you're doing
something [__] disgusting. It's about
the fact you're behaving like a [__]
loser. And I hate seeing it. I hate
looking at it. I hate seeing it. I hate
knowing that you're you exist and you're
acting this way out in the world. And if
I have any way of contacting you, I'm
going to make sure I go and tell you
exactly how I feel about it.
>> Me?
Wait, it all makes sense now. Oh, come
on, Ral. That's a little weird, man. Is
it Is it Is it Oh my god. It's just
because Dev is closer to me. Oh no.
>> Gossip like a woman. Cry about it. Cry
about it. That's awesome.
>> Jealous of my closest.
>> We love gossiping. We love rumors. It
isn't because It isn't because who can
get closer to Dev. It's about who can
get closer to me because they're both
chasers. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my
god.
>> Hassan is bad so nobody's really going
to care if you lie about him. Dev gains
social capital by lying about Hassan.
>> Vague posting hat. Vague. I love vague
posting t-shirt.
Vague posting. I'm vague posting sign.
>> Recent Trump shooter we Assan fan.
Instead of arguing in the replies for
his position, he does a quote retweet
battle where he substantiates nothing.
The goal here isn't to prove that Hassan
is wrong or more specifically that
Hassan does harmful content that creates
politically vi
>> I'm pretty sure uh uh Dev is married.
No, I'm I'm No, I don't think they're
married yet. Um though, to be fair, like
um I think I think Dev has told me that
um she is the one. Like she is the one.
So they seem to be pretty like confident
that like she is the one. Yeah,
>> the one. Wow.
>> And it seems like they do get along. So
good for Tom.
>> Like Neo,
>> violent people. The goal here is to look
like you're a
>> like Neo. She's She's dodging SFO's lies
about the trans women he's flirting
with. He's dodging SFO's lies.
>> She be doing with that scarf around her
neck toe. Droplet emoji. Droplet emoji.
Scarf emoji. Eyes.
>> Thank you for the $10, Jimly. Thank you
for the $10, Jim. That's disgusting.
Thank you.
>> Genius debater who owned Hassan on
Twitter. You look smart to the droolian
DG cumg guzzlers. You've aligned
yourself.
>> What the [__] Yo, I'm telling you,
dude. Reverse flash. Okay. Professor
Zoom. Okay, Prof.
>> Guys, I promise we'll get to the good
part soon. I promise. I promise.
>> Professor Zoom. Okay. All right. Reverse
Flash only aspires to have this level of
hatred. Dude, what in the dude? This guy
is the hater of haters. What the [__]
Like actually insane.
Actually, insane levels of hatred right
here.
>> Insane levels of hatred, guys.
>> Nothing. Ultimately, you lied about
Hassan and you will never take
accountability for this lie or the
several others I will point out in this
video. Because with a dying YouTube
channel and nothing really going for
you, what more can you really do while
you sit on your lard ass all day playing
pedophile slop games? really pushing
boundaries with the 13 live concurrent
fatty the step up in debate line dev so
proudly
>> bro what am I watching right now bro the
unhinged energy is off the charts
>> shouts is also extremely pathetic given
his constantly ran from Jtock a streamer
who is opposed to destiny this is
important because instead of debating
Jtock talking to him directly or DMing
him
>> it it's because it's because Jtock has
trouble progressing in his career career
because he's stuck on kick. That's why.
So, he wants to latch onto any platform
in order to gain some kind of leverage
or gain a new audience or something,
right? Like for example, like I have no
doubt that JTO will probably like um
agree to or Jtock or whatever. Okay,
just talking um Geoster, whatever. Like
I I I like I I am convinced that he is
is is just trying to um gain a foothold
on YouTube, right? Oh, well that's
perfect then because I think SFO is
trying to gain a foothold on YouTube as
well
>> outside of Ral Kitten House. Outside of
RA Kitten House.
>> That sounds like that sounds perfect
though. They should collaborate as this
YouTube editor essentially. But
>> he would rather gossip in Destiny's
offline chat about him. Jtock tags him
in his server to confront him for lying
and Dev doesn't respond. Dev makes a
claim about Pixie using the court system
in bad faith. says he was proven right
and yet again Juck confronts him and he
doesn't
>> Yeah, maybe SFO would get more than 13
uh live concurrent viewers if he
collabed with literally anyone other
than Wick. You know, maybe if he debated
someone other than Wick, he would he
would get more than 13 current viewers.
>> Respond. Dev is extremely willing to
make claims about people without
substantiation. He will say Pixie is an
evil suck.
>> I I mean like to be fair, right? Like
just to be very fair, I I don't think I
don't think they deserve like any amount
of good faith, right? Like normally if
this was about like anybody else, if
this was about anybody else, I would
probably be like, "Oh, Deb, why don't
you talk to this person? This person
seems to be reasonable and they're
calling you out." But these anti fans
are not reasonable. These anti fans are
not reasonable and and they're not like
just calling out for the sake of calling
out. They want to get a dunk on you and
they want it to be on like
>> guys, they're being mean. So, actually,
you don't need to reply to any of the
points where they clearly prove that
you're lying for your own personal gain
cuz they're being mean. So, you actually
don't you actually don't need to respond
to the fact that you've been clearly
shown to be lying for personal gain.
>> Basically, like Yeah. Like they aren't
there to have a good faith discussion
about whether or not like Steven is
guilty or not. They just want to be
there because they really [__] hate
the guy and they want to see his career
fail and you know, whatever, right?
>> Well, no, it's all about destiny.
Everything's about destiny. never
explain himself. This results in Dev
constantly virtue signaling, doing
performative activism, and running
constantly from debates, all while
criticizing Hassan for doing the same
exact thing. What if I told you Dev
actually had a pattern of lying, though,
and this wasn't just the one instance
with Hassan? Let's start small. Someone
asks Dev if he's okay with pedophiles in
his community. Dev says, "No, that's why
I banned you." In contrast, here's a
clip of Dev saying he feels bad about
banning pedophiles in his community as
long as they're not preying on children
in his Discord.
>> If I knew for sure that someone on my
server was trying to ddle kids, then I'd
ban them like 100%. Yeah, but like off
your server though. Hey Dev, what's up?
Hey Snider, what's up?
>> Oh man.
>> Like if none of it was happening in your
spaces, it just I don't know. It feels
It feels wrong to me.
>> I don't I don't care what's wrong with
what he just said. Am I Am I the only
one that like knows how to differ like
between like feelsbased statements and
like
>> So, dude, how brilliant is this? It's
there's actually nothing wrong or weird
about what SFO said there because it was
a feels statement. It was an emotional
statement. So, it's it's not there's
nothing weird there. Like, when food
shop says that she feels like she's
attracted to children, uh there's
nothing weird about saying that because
it's a feeling statement, guys. It's a
feeling statement. So it it actually
it's actually not weird at all and you
can't make any criticism because it's a
feeling statement. Guys, morale didn't
say that it was a rule in his Discord.
He doesn't ban pedophiles. He didn't say
it was a rule, did he? He present He
presented the clip as Dev says it.
Affirmative. Am I Am I the only one that
like knows how to differ like between
like feelsbased statements and like
affirmative prescriptions on what you
should do? It sounds bad, but then like
it doesn't it isn't that bad. I like
Okay.
>> Reference to Lilith. Love it being a fan
of Shadow.
>> You literally cannot come up with a
coherent argument for that. Not the food
shops ever can, frankly. Food shops is
legitimately [__] Uh but yeah,
literally nothing there. Nothing there.
Sentence just trailed off like many do.
>> Me for saying I came without evidence.
>> Literally, who gives a [__] Like I hope
I hope people realize that like for
years like Dev was friends with Sargon
of a cat. Like this guy
>> is the most problematic one one of the
most problematic British people of all
time. Okay. One of the most
consequential problematic British people
of
>> literally everything food shop just said
there is like totally [__] [__]
Sargon's one of the most problematic
British people of all time. Uh, no. Not
even close. Um, I don't even know where
to start on that one. I literally don't
even know where to start on that one.
Uh, there's a long [__] history. A
long [__] history to this country.
Okay, second one. Most consequential
problematic British people. Let's just
take modern times, okay? Let's take our
rough lifetimes. Last, you know, 30 or
so years. last 30 or so years, you know,
our lifetimes, guys. Last 30 or so
years, he's not even he's not remotely
one of the most consequential Brit pro
problematic British people in that time
frame. He's not remotely consequential.
He could not even he could not even come
close to winning election. What what did
he get like 1% of the vote when he ran
for an election? It was [__] crazy.
He's a nobody. He's a YouTuber. He's
he's just like a total nobody. They're
just like the idea that he's like super
consequential. No, he made this weekend
stupid where he read the Guardian and
said it was really dumb to 25,000
people. It's just crazy. Absolute crazy
read. And then additionally, let's
disregard just specific statements
there. Food chops are saying, "Well,
obviously SFO has no issue hanging out
with pedophiles. He hung out with Sargon
of Aad who says racist things
sometimes." Again, where where do you
even start? Where do you even start with
that analogy? Where do you even begin
breaking that down? Yeah, there's
there's nothing about that that
indicates is an active personal threat
to children to children. It's it's an
abstract second order consequence of his
political advocacy consequence that
you're concerned about with Sargon.
Whereas in the case of a pedophile, you
were concerned about the immediate
impact on the social circle, your
family, you know, people you may know.
of all time. Okay. Like I I don't know
why like this is pointing towards little
love it love it when like Dev has been
like best friends with Sargon for years.
>> This is funny considering he had no
evidence for the Assan shooter thing but
sure let me substantiate my claim unlike
you. In 2018 Lilith Love it did a
cosplay of Shadman. This was after
Shadman sexualized
>> Wait when? 2018. Bro, you have to dig up
like the [__] dinosaur excavation
brush for this one. Like what the [__]
>> He's banned from every Pizza Hut in
>> Swindon's daughter and Lieutenant
Corbus. Lilith love it also promoted the
same DIY website.
>> Oh, she's like, bro, that was in 2018.
2018? What? Who cares? 2018? Like, how
long does that go? 8 years ago, bro. I
bet that dude when when 8 years ago, Mal
was probably in his [__] baby's crib.
Like, what the [__] Keles, the same one
with the lollcon packaging. The same one
that was criticized for attempting to
>> The point of it being 2018 is it's post
when Shadman was drawing real kids.
That's the point.
>> Circumvent parents in order to give
children hormone replacement therapy.
Dev is also friends with food shops who
claim to have POCD so severe they had to
cross the street in order to avoid
spontaneous child abuse.
>> Like for example, Oh my god, not this
[__] again, bro. Oh my god. every time.
Every time, bro. But I wouldn't even
walk on the same side of the street as a
kid. Like in real life, just because I
had POCD, I was definitely scared of
kids. Yeah. I was just like incredibly
definitely scared of kids in general
because I would be so scared that I was
like a real pedophile.
>> I like I like how like he's playing this
as if like Mal hasn't himself said that
he would hit on a 17-year-old and he and
he would like knowingly hit on a
17-year-old.
>> Well, he wouldn't now. Okay. He wouldn't
now. He did once when he was like 20 or
21. He did once when he was like 20 or
21. He wouldn't do it now. Okay.
Hopefully. We hope. I don't think. But
he did do it once when he was 20 or 21,
which is like, you know, it's really not
that crazy. I don't know, man. It's It's
not good obviously, but it's not that
[__] crazy really, is it?
>> 17year-old. Okay. So, really nice
projection there that I would convince
myself I was a bad even being like
like the same air as children would be
like viol like be a violation.
>> Food shops would attempt to show email
>> like I I don't I don't
>> who hasn't done that once or thrice.
Okay.
>> Showing this just mainly because like I
think this was during a time I think
this was during a time which like
>> why else would you become a streamer?
This is what dickers actually thinks
guys. This is what dickers actually
thinks. I was like really really open
with the internet about like my various
mental disorders especially OCD right
and even if it sounds like bad at first
the only reason I'm saying these out in
the open in the first place is because
like I was cognizant right I was
cognizant of oh yeah I have this issue
I'm going to go treat it right but like
these people don't believe in any kind
of mental help or therapy or anything
OCD right this was during
>> jobs would attempt to show email
>> like I I don't I don't like like I don't
quite understand what exactly is the
point of like showing this just mainly
because like I think this was during a
time I think
>> well the point of showing this is that
you provably lied food shops. That's the
point of showing this is that you
provably lied. You lied and said that
this email contained correspondence that
substantiated the idea that you were
prescribed lolly for POCD. Mhm. All this
email talks about is anxiety and
mentions OCD in passing. No mention of
POCD. Certainly no mention of lolly.
It's not a thing that's in there. I
think this was during a time which like
I was like really really open with the
internet about like my various mental
disorders, especially OCD, right? And
even if it sounds like bad at first, the
only reason I'm saying these out in the
open in the first place is because like
I was cognizant, right? I was cognizant
of, oh yeah, I have this issue. I'm
going to go treat it. Right. But like
these people don't believe in any kind
of mental health or therapy or anything.
So it's like Yeah. I wouldn't expect
them to understand it, right?
>> No. No. I'm pretty sure pretty much
everyone criticizing you right now does
believe in like mental health and
therapy and all that stuff. They just
don't believe you went food shops. They
don't believe you went really. Um I
don't I don't think food shops really
significantly attended therapy. Uh I
think food shops mainly did online stuff
and basically just got meds. I think is
essentially food shops engagement with
therapy and mental help. I think all the
other stuff is a bunch of madeup
[__] um that's basically stolen from
Mr. Girl streams, Mr. Girl and Destiny
streams
>> to justify their therapist supposedly
prescribing loll pornography.
>> Like like what do like seriously what
what was I supposed to say? Like oh
yeah, I should like on purpose be closer
to kids. Like is that is that something
that like the anti-ven want me to do
back then? Is is just like be closer to
kids? Is that the is that the other
prescription? You're comfortable with
that? Like
>> as an answer to this troubling problem.
The email had nothing about Loi or POCD
included. Later, food shops admitted
that loi was only briefly mentioned.
>> So, you've been to therapy for the PCD
thing. Uh, and you consume lolli
separately. So, have you have you ever
told
>> I went to I went to therapy for OCD in
general? Sure. Yeah.
>> So, have you ever have you does your the
the lolly consumption does that come up
in your therapy sessions? You don't have
to tell me. This is deep lore. This is
deep lore. Okay. Like unironically.
>> So, dude, why did Loneox say this, man?
Why the [__] did Loneox say all this
[__] on this [__] stream, bro?
There's there's another clip of him as
well where does he say? What does he
say? He's uh he's on this panel and he
goes, "Oh, I don't know why food shops
are sh I don't know why food shops are
sharing this with you guys. It seems
like she did everything she could and
tried to get help and all you guys just
attack her for it." And everyone's like,
"Dude, I don't think you I don't think
you've looked into this. I don't think
you looked into this."
>> Mentioned.
>> So, you've been to therapy for the PCD
thing. Uh, and you consume lolly
separately. So, have you have you ever
told
>> I went to
>> I I went to therapy for OCD in general?
Sure. Yeah.
>> So, have you ever have you does your the
the lolly consumption? Does that come up
in your therapy sessions? You don't have
to tell me.
>> This is deep lore. This is deep lore.
Okay. Like unironically,
>> uh, it came up in one session only and
only as a side tangent. Food shops lied
about being prescribed lollycon porn to
attempt to justify consumption and even
views.
>> No, I don't think I've lied at any point
over the course of that drama. Okay,
>> dude. It's so [__] obscene. It's so
[__] crazy. And just think there's
like 20 DJs who are actually [__]
stupid enough to believe this [__]
There's actually still like 20 DJs that
it's only 20, but there's still about 20
DJers that are still [__] stupid
enough to believe this. Most of them
totally turned while Dan was, you know,
in his crusade, but there is still
about, you know, 20 to 50 of them that
actually do still believe that. So, it's
pretty crazy. It's pretty crazy.
>> And like it's it's almost like
physically impossible for me to
knowingly lie just mainly.
>> It's peak. It's peak. the greatest
pedophile self-defense since Prince
Andrew. Guys, he couldn't sweat. Food
chops physically medically cannot lie.
Okay, guys. Food shops physically
medically cannot lie due to having OCD.
OCD gives us such a crippling fear of
guilt. It is physically impossible to
lie, guys. The most trustworthy person
alive. Just disregard all evidence and
even views. No, I don't think I've lied
at any point over the course of that
drama. Okay. And and like it's it's
almost like physically impossible for me
to knowingly lie just mainly because
like um I think also part of OCD is like
this um fear of like guilt, right? And I
think that if I ever knowingly lied like
I would feel really really guilty about
it.
>> So it's like like it's almost physically
impossible for me to knowingly lie. Like
it that's not that's not possible,
right? What is What is this video? I
don't know. Like I would like to say
like it's a dev video, but like
apparently it's automatically
transitioned to being like a food shops
anti-fan video, which is like fantastic.
Okay, you know what? Three to four years
ago. Hell yeah. Bring it all up again.
Okay, just so you know, okay, like this
brown guy probably still has a crush on
me, so I I don't know why.
>> Just to literally just throwing anything
at the wall now. Throwing anything at
the wall. where I just showed how this
person totally [__] lied about their
mental disorder to try and sound like
less of a pedophile and it's just
throwing anything at the wall. Totally
spazzing. I It's physically impossible
for me to lie. Also, this guy wants to
[__] me. Just literally anything
>> who says all these things. All right.
It's all very suspicious to me. Like,
does he want to be the kid in this
scenario in like a roleplay sex
scenario? Kind of weird if you ask me.
Okay, but
>> Lolly has drawn child pornography.
>> Yes, I consume lollycon. Okay. Yes, I
recognize it is drawn child pornography.
I disagree with this. Um I think that
simply like at the end of the day
>> me watching me watching a clip of
myself. Yeah, I just don't agree with
this. Me watching a clip myself say this
guy's not talking any s this guy's
talking crazy.
>> Implies that there's an actual child
victim. But okay,
>> I disagree with
>> say food shops isn't a pedophile, but
really let's just hear it from food
shops themselves.
>> Let's say you're a pedophile and you're
trying to hold yourself off with
lollycon lolly, right? To try and like
hold yourself off so you don't I am a
pedophile. I like femininity.
>> Yeah, that's a joke. That's what jokes
are.
>> But do you like it more or less than
like
>> So, that one was a joke.
>> Femininity.
>> I want a cute little girl that I can
wrap my arms around. I need to I need to
have a little girl to wrap myself
around. I need to have like a
12-year-old.
>> It's hard to take.
>> Yeah, this is shock humor. Okay. Um,
this is three.
>> Yo, shock humor. Where you talk about
your attraction to 12y olds where you
say that you're sexually attracted to
12-year-olds. You'd like to have a
sexual interaction with 12. Yeah. Shock
chalk humor. Shock chalk humor. Guys,
we've all seen shock jock humor like
that before, right?
>> Four years ago, like like back when I
was a um earlier content creator, like I
was like way crazy. I was comedy guys.
>> It's all just very embarrassing now. But
yeah, I mean there's there's nothing
else I can do, okay? Like like these are
just like really embarrassing clips now.
But yeah.
>> Why are they embarrassing? I thought
>> nowadays I definitely watch what I'm
saying. But yeah,
>> debit his word.
>> Remember this guy has these saved. Yes,
you should reread your manifesto. [__]
no. Okay, good try. Okay, peaceful
clipper. All right, good try. Okay,
>> when he is so obviously psychosexually
compromised at the sight of a borderline
crossdresser really taking in the
pre-transition photos as he went along.
His wife even caught on to this, making
fun of him for chasing midtrans hole on
Twitter.
>> Oh man, so
>> I got a private message of scrum.
>> Oh, now we're back to death. Okay,
>> Trump's he was talking to other people.
It was like leaked to me. Okay.
>> A few months ago.
>> Okay.
>> He was He's now saying that apparently I
was like in love with Lilith and I was
pining over her while he was [__] her
the whole time.
>> Like
>> I I think as far I'm concerned like
Lilith Love It and like SFO they're just
friends. Like I don't I don't think I've
ever seen a clip of them having any kind
of romantic tension between them ever.
Like it's it's a really weird thing to
kind of like put out there that like a
man and a woman can't be friends with
one another because well like if if if a
man and a woman are friends like one of
them has to have feelings for the other.
I think it's just ultimately a very
toxic mindset to have. But you know I
just like I don't know the like these
concepts are like foreign to people like
me who just like stay online all day and
then like
>> where was that in the video? Where was
that? No, they're mouse presenting you
with Dev's wife saying that he did have
interest. It's not just, oh, men and
women can't be friends, even though, you
know, I mean, it's kind of argument,
whatever. It's not just saying that
blanket. It is a clear specific example
where Dev's wife is expressing it very
clearly, but you just have to you just
have to look at it and lie. Sorry. Can't
possibly be lying. Physically
impossible. So, that can't be the case.
They can't they literally cannot
conceive of any kind of like [__]
normal friendship between a man and a
woman. It's just silly but
>> completely [__]
>> also just so you know Lilith is Lilith
Love it is trans and I would not be
surprised if Ral also wanted to [__]
her. Okay, like out of spite.
>> Delusional [__]
>> She's cute but no, I was never
interested because I'm not like a
[__] [__] s.
>> That's not [__] true. You flirted.
Oh,
>> really?
Okay.
>> I feel like I feel like ultimately like
maybe this is just something I disagree
with, but like I don't see anything
wrong with people flirting with friends
all that much. I think that I think that
there are limits to draw. Like I don't
think you should cross the boundary into
cheating, but like I don't know, man.
Like maybe this is just like me being
gay and then like having like female
friends or whatever the heck, but like
all the female friends would just like
flirt openly with other female friends.
I don't [__] know. Like like even if
even if like they were already like they
had another partner or something. It's
just Yeah. I mean maybe like like here's
the thing. I can't speak for Dev's
relationship. I can't. Okay. But I can I
can only say things that I myself have
seen, right? And I myself have seen I
don't think I've seen much of like
Lilith and um Dev. Okay. But
>> got to do this without getting
swallowed. Anyway,
>> it was it was ridiculous.
>> Commencing guidance protocol. Their eyes
have
>> like the only time I think I've ever had
Dev approach me about Lilith is when
like um when it was like more of a
personal emergency and it had nothing to
do with romance. Yeah.
pining. Definitely not.
>> Want wanted a good digging down from
Yes.
>> Can I just not have any honest real
conversation with you anymore because
you're like this right now.
>> Listen. Listen.
>> He's so hot. He's so [__] hurt, bro.
What the [__]
>> I don't get swallowed.
>> Can you restart?
>> I don't know how to restart.
>> I don't know. I'm I'm asking if you can.
>> Okay. Not like actual flirting, just
like casual just being like like [__]
Twitter flirt. You [__] say you'll
[__] traps on Twitter all the time.
>> Ruin my run, you stupid [__]
>> Oh, that's real.
>> Okay, for it to be an actual flirt and
not just a joke, there has to be real
intent behind it.
>> Chat, I need a poll. I need a poll about
>> no garden this year, Astro. I
>> I I feel like flirting like implies that
there is like you want to go somewhere
with it, right? Like there there is
intent behind it, right? But like there
is such thing as like God, what do you
call platonic flirting? There is no such
thing as platonic flirting, right? I'm
so confused. Yeah. But also like I'm not
here to comment on like any kind of
relationship problems that Dev may have
because he has a long history. He has he
has a long history of like him um having
his history online, right? Um
>> yeah, a long history of having his
history online.
>> Like I can like here's the thing that's
kind of right. Um, Dev's own
relationship problems are his own
relationship problems. Okay. Ultimately,
at the end of the day, okay, but like
this snarking means very little to me,
right? Because
>> Okay, but you're accepting this
demonstrates relationship problems
though. So, you've accepted the framing
this demonstrates relationship problems.
Okay, no problem. Can move on with that
point then. No one cares if you care
about the snark [__] any anti-fan if
any anti-fan would go on to like also
stream their life like this. If any
anti-fan were to also stream their life
like this, I don't think it would be
even close to as like good as this. I
mean, right? Like much less like being
in the same room as a woman, right?
>> See
Ralph streaming his life 24/7. He's
rolling out of bed, eating a bunch
eating a bunch of food. He's like
sitting down rubbing his belly and
groaning about how much food he's eaten.
Edits for 20 minutes on a video he's
been working on for eight months. Loads
up Destiny 2. Plays Destiny 2 for the
rest of the day. Messages women on
Discord repping this [__] 75% messaging
women on Discord. It's not their mom or
their sister. Okay. But like, yeah, I
don't know. Um I like this is just none
of my business. Like any kind of
relationship issue, that's not my
business unless like I'm being asked
about it. Unless like like I'm actually
being like because you know Dev is a
close associate of mine. So like I'm not
I'm not here to like [__] get in
between him and you know his partner of
like 10 years by the way. Okay. But yeah
>> about whether or not telling a woman
you'd [__] her on Twitter counts as
flirting.
>> Identified commencing.
>> Intent is a part of flirting.
>> Their eyes have long attributed.
>> I'm not cheating. I'm just goofing
around.
It's not cheating though.
>> Dev framing his relationship with Lilith
as normal is a bit dishonest. He was
really interested in this trans
>> I can help you.
>> Oh no. I was watching mass reactions. My
bad. I was caught. I'm caught. I'm
caught.
>> Twitter account.
>> Also, I'm not entirely sure like what's
the point of showing this. Like what
exactly is the point of showing this?
>> That he would go on to her Kiwi Farms
thread and start defending her from a
logs. Not well. Mind you, a lot of the
messages are just gross sexual comments.
Uh, but an attempt was made nonetheless.
Dev also lied in my little Twitter spat
with
>> Wait, wait, who? Mass reactions
relatable. It's nice. I I I actually
rewatched um the mass reaction to Into
the Spider-Verse and across the
Spiderverse.
>> Wow. We don't care.
>> It It's actually Wait like years until
to see. Yeah, it just feels really
That's why I enjoy and genuine flirting.
I agree with that to distinguish between
friendly flirty compliments and genuine
flirting. I agree with that. Which is
why like if there's like enough
communication, I just don't see what's
wrong, I guess, right? And I assume that
they communicate about this like
offscreen a lot. The fact that they are
still together, I don't know, should
indicate to you that they probably go
and solve their issues, right? Unless
like maybe they are completely immature
and whatever at the age of like 30
something. Like I just doubt I just
doubt like there is actually any like
real issue here. If it doesn't work out
for them in the end, then I don't see
how that's like the issue of any of the
anti-fans. I I just don't get like if
whether or not the relationship works
out is none of the anti-fans business,
but they're going to make it their
business because, you know, they're
going to be snarking on the
relationship, right? they're going to be
snarking on the circumstances of um you
know Deb's relationship with her which
is like I think just
>> I just I don't even want to comment on
that message about moral. It's just like
real ones know everything I'd say about
that. Real ones know everything I'd say
about that.
>> Douchebag thing to do right. um like
your your relationship failures and
successes. Um like being judged by
people on the internet, especially when
Dev is being open about his relationship
by gaming with his girlfriend is just I
don't know. It's just it's just
disgusting. Okay. In my opinion. But
okay.
>> I'm not cheating. I'm just goofing
around.
>> It's not cheating though.
>> Dev framing his relationship with Lilith
as normal is a bit dishonest. He was
really interested in this trans baddy.
So much so that he would go onto her
Kiwi Farms thread and start defending
her from a logs. Not well, mind you, a
lot.
>> Wouldn't you defend a friend? Wouldn't
you defend a friend? Like this is
another like weird thing that like
literally nobody in the real world would
be able to relate to, by the way. Like
nobody in the real world would be like,
"Oh well, ah, see they're in love with
one another." Like I like I need more
evidence than this. By the way, these
like anti-fans, they pride themselves on
evidence. They pride themselves on like
whatever the [__] right? But like
clearly there are holes, right? Like
like where is the evidence that like
since you made a claim here that Dev was
into Lilith, right? Where's the like
where's the evidence outside of like
>> his his wife saying it, the the extended
argument he had with his wife about it?
um Dev and his um girlfriend having like
a brief spat over it right in public.
Like where exactly is the evidence?
Because I don't see it. Like yeah,
there's a clear lack of like shown proof
of any of these claims.
>> Lot of the messages are just gross
sexual comments. Uh but an attempt was
made nonetheless. Dev also lied in my
little Twitter spat with him doing yet
another quote retweet which I'm sure
makes him
>> bro this just like number one hater type
[__] bro like the hatred the hatred okay
the hatred is crazy feel super badass
saying how he doesn't pay attention to
my part of the internet implying he
never saw Jtock's offer to debate this
is such an obvious lie I don't know why
he even typed this out I have personally
seen short photaku in Quean's chat. He
is called into Turkey Tom streams. He
made a video about Chuga Conroy. He
calls into Wick streams frequently. You
engage with Destiny. You go into his
offline chat and [__] talk Jtock when
you're too scared to say it to his face.
So much for those [__] safe spaces
you constantly complain.
>> Well, why why should I guess my question
is like why shouldn't you lie to
anti-fans? I think I think at some point
during my coverage, I think I think I've
literally said that these people do not
deserve your good faith.
>> So, dude, isn't this brilliant? Isn't
this [__] brilliant? Physically,
medically incapable of lying, but it's
absolutely justified to lie. Okay,
you're allowed to lie. You should lie.
Feel free to lie to these people, but
I'm physically incapable of doing it.
Okay? So, do as I say, not as I do. I
literally can't use this tactic. I'm
physically incapable of doing it because
it would make me feel so guilty. It
would make me feel so guilty because
it's so wrong. But lying is justified.
It's justified and you should do it
because [__] these people. But I can't
because it's wrong. So I'm physically
incapable of doing it because of the
guilt. Are you following, guys? Are you
following? Hopefully we're all following
food's train of thought here. I I feel
like I feel like
>> it sounds plausible to me. Good thing
SFO stuck his neck out for this stupid
[__] [__] doesn't it?
>> The lessons that I have taught like
during my coverages about the anti-fans
essentially speaking, right? Like I feel
like I've taught like a lot of these
lessons about like, oh yeah, I do think
it's justified to lie to these people
because they're wretched. They're
they're like wretched stalkers, right?
So like I don't know. Like I I feel like
that's just kind of adhering to adhering
to that. No
>> by the way. In January, Dev tweets out
saying, "I actively killed my own
channel rather than sell out to MAGA. I
have zero regrets." This frames teaching
one unwilling to sacrifice his values
for things like money or social
influence. Dev lied about Hassan.
>> If you duck people don't get to call
other people. Are you talking about Dev?
Because Dev has debated anti-fans
before. I'm pretty sure I covered it
before.
>> And when he was proven wrong, he refused
to engage. Dev ran from debating Jtock
and lied saying he doesn't pay attention
to the
>> Wait, wait. Is it Is it JTO declining to
speak to Steven?
>> Thank you for the $5 Jimly. Thank you.
Huge appreciated.
>> Or is it Steven declining to speak with
Jtock? Because one of them is definitely
avoiding the other, right? Yeah, I'm
pretty sure. Wait, right. I'm I I don't
I don't see any reason for Steven to
turn down like an encounter with JTOK,
but yeah, who knows?
>> He himself is in as justification. Dev
has a history of saying doxing is bad.
>> They stalk, they dox, and they're not
above IRL harassment, including 4chan
>> because because most of the time doxing
is not justified, right? Like if if I
were to say colloquially killing people
is wrong. That doesn't mean that I'm not
like and in the next breath I say that,
oh, killing in self-defense is right.
That's not like like obviously what I
mean by killing is like murdering,
right? Like if I say killing is bad,
right? Obviously, I'm talking
colloquially speaking, in most cases,
killing is bad, right? Like, dude, like
this is a level of autism that like is
obviously like such bad faith autism.
Like, just completely unserious people
like completely right
>> and prank [__] like ordering a bunch of
pizzas and taxi cabs to someone's house.
>> Yet, he participates in communities
where doxing is not only done but
justified and celebrated. Short fat
otaku is a coward, a liar, an
unprincipled loser grasping desperately
for any sense of relevancy by epically
quote tweeting Hassan despite very
clearly being in the wrong. But hey,
Hassan is bad, so it's all justified. I
guess the entire point of principal
>> Yeah, but but it's not just like, oh
yeah, Hassan is bad. Okay,
>> it's it's funny that the anti-fans say
this, but like these days, do you know
what they're doing? They're defending
Hassan.
>> Correct. They are actively defending
Hassan. Okay.
>> That's what Yeah. Yeah. So
that's what you do when someone is being
treated in ways that go against your
principles. When someone's speech is
being attacked, you defend their speech.
When someone's being lied about, you
defend their character. Um so so yeah,
that that is true. Yeah, people do
defend Assan cuz he is worth defending
because you people lie about him and
break your principles to try and get rid
of him. So yeah, is contributing an
absolutely worthless message as always.
Thank you. So yeah, that that is people
do defend good actually
>> that Hassan is bad or or that being like
a caveat or whatever is that they are
actively like praising Hassan. Seven
months. I have infiltrated the discord
and collected information on littering
to pass on to the FBI. It's only a
matter of time. Okay. Thank you, Megan,
for the tier five. I appreciate the
seven months. Okay. You've always been a
very close supporter and I app um No,
you're not is No, you're not. First of
all, you're not the only person chat who
who attempts to disagree. Uh you're just
actually the dumbest one. I don't know
if you've noticed this, but you actually
never make a point. You actually never
make a point. When you attempt to make
points, you've put them in the form of
questions instead so you can walk back
when you're called [__] for them.
Um, there are other people who disagree,
but you don't say anything substantive
ever.
>> Appreciate the dono. Yes, I do
appreciate the renewal. Also, like I I
just want to say like, yeah, Dev is
wrong here, okay? Like he is he's not
correct, okay? But like, bro, the
[__] anti-fans dicks suck. Hassan now
they dick suck Hassan now right like
shamelessly I'm saying crazy style one
might even say
>> Hassan is my best friend I talk to
Hassan every day I talk to son every day
I talk to him all the time we're really
good friends we talk about fashion we
talk about fashion I let him know listen
that outfit's not going down well listen
that suit is not going down well got a
geography teacher on the top half wigger
on the bottom half let's change this up
a bit by a full
like wet sloppy toppy style, okay? Like
like we're not just talking about like
begrudgingly saying, "Oh yeah, Hassan
bad." Like I'm talking about like
they're actively worshiping this
[__] okay? Like Jelk literally
set up his Twitch times so then he could
possibly get raided by Hassan. So in
case one day he ever gets raided by
Hassan, um like his Twitch times line up
so then he starts after Hassan. Like I
have seen it before. I have seen him say
that before. It is embarrassing. Okay.
Like this is not just begrudgingly
saying that her song is bad. This is
like actively dick sucking him. Okay.
But
>> is that they work for people you don't
like.
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, moral, I think
Aiden Paladin is wrong in her SFO fight,
though. I'm not sure.
>> Or even your enemies. Dev is compromised
and will lie about people he doesn't
like to defame them. And will lie about
people he does like to try to make them
seem less bad than they actually. He
hasn't lied at all. Okay. Any any kind
of inconsistency was probably because
like due to three to four years ago like
I was actively crashing out. So then
like obviously I'm not going to be
perfect in terms of speaking. Right now
I am. Okay. Now I'm confident in the way
that I talk about things. Okay. But like
back then, no. Back then like yeah I was
an inconsistent mess cuz I was crashing
out. Right. Like you have to keep in
mind that I have the entirety of like
Twitch poll like railing against me. So
obviously if Dev cares about me and he's
willing to defend me and he's asking me
questions, I give him inconsistent
answers, right? Which then puts him in a
tough position of trying to be
consistent, if that makes sense, right?
So obviously because I'm the one
>> Wait, but Dev said he'd looked into all
of this. Wait, but Dev said he'd looked
into all this and you were and that he
wanted to defend you. Now you're saying
he just asked you and you gave him
answers. He's just repeating what you
said so he can't be lying. Oh,
>> giving him inconsistent answers at the
time because I was crashing out, right?
It's not his fault. It's not his fault.
No, just put it on me instead. Me from
the past.
>> Are Dev is the very thing he rants about
in his videos and complains about on
Twitter.
>> There is way more I could put in
>> shaken.
>> Hey, Purtle man, thank you so much for
the $5. I appreciate that. Also, I just
want to say this, okay? Like remember,
okay, if you donate, you get to make
moral mad, okay? Because I'm pretty sure
Moral like [__] burns the fuse out.
>> Pulling out all the stops tonight.
Jesus. Really need that. Really needs
that money. Really needs to make much
money I make despite like my lower
viewership these days. Okay. Cuz
apparently my lower viewership has like
no massive impact on my money at the
very least. So I think he's jealous of
that. So just remember just remember if
you want to make mad you just have to
donate more. Okay? If there's any
motivation to donate, there you go. here
like him trying to defend himself on his
own kiwi farm store. 2018 internet
pressure was well it wasn't 2018 like
this was um 2023ish
like times 2024 2023 like it was like
like obviously 2 to three years isn't
entirely in entirely like a lifet
like I was making way bigger mistakes
right but yeah YouTube does seem to give
you the top ads does that even indicate
anything does the top ads even indicate
anything I I I'm not sure because people
have said that before people have talked
about like the the the quality of the
ads, but I'm not sure if that actually
indicates anything, though.
>> I'm a guy. I'm a guy. I'm a guy. I'm a
guy.
>> What?
>> Hey, uh Masaki, thank you so much for
the five gifted memberships. And Squall,
thank you so much for the benefactor
tier three renewal. Okay, much
appreciated. See, this is what I like
about this community so much. Okay,
every single time the anti-fans try to
embarrass me or they try to like go
after me or whatever, my community just
comes together. Okay, they come together
to defend each other. Okay, they come
together to make sure that everyone is
[__] living it out there. Okay, they
make sure to remind the anti-fans that
they're employed, they have their own
lives, and uh yeah, they have hoes, they
have money, and they're married. Okay,
>> so you know, that's what I like about
this community is that
>> thank you for the five gifted weed.
Thank you.
I I imagine that is those are qualities
that I imagine food shops viewers
having. Employed, get hoes, married.
What else did you say that sure that
everyone is like go after me or
whatever. My community just comes
together, okay? They come together to
defend each other, okay? They come
together to make sure that everyone is
[__]
>> Weed is in like some polycill. I'm like
not even joking. I'm pretty sure this
guy is like legit in some polycill. So,
I think this guy gets hosed. I think
this guy gets hosed. I imagine he's
employed though. I get I get the
feeling, you know, when someone if
someone tells me they're in like a
Polycule and I hear them with a northern
accent, I'm assuming they bounce from
like job to job and probably like, you
know, kind of live like a scumbag.
That's kind of what I assume. Sound like
a fan right now because I said you look
like a scumbag. But yeah, I don't I
don't have much confidence in Well, I
mean, Jim's got a job. Jim's Jim's job.
Married, kids. That's another That's a
donator. He's a fed. Yeah, but I
shouldn't be any of those things. Sorry,
Queen. I'm a loser, Chud. Okay. Living
it out there. Come. Every single time
the anti-fans try to embarrass me or
they try to like go after me or
whatever, my community just comes
together, okay? They come together to
defend each other, okay? They come
together to make sure that everyone is
[__]
>> Jimly actually I've actually heard rumor
that Jimly may be uh leaving his wife,
children and job uh to commit fulltime
to marathon. I've actually I've actually
been hearing rumors of this that this
guy is uh is on Marathon all day every
day and may soon be abandoning his his
wife and children living it out there.
Okay. They make sure to remind the
anti-fans that they're employed. They
have their own lives and uh yeah, they
have hoes, they have money, and they're
married. Okay, so you know, that's what
I like about this community is that like
everyone here touches grass, okay? And
they actually analyze things
realistically, okay, and not analyze
things. No,
>> we back on marathon now. We back on um
anti-fan lens, okay? Yeah. I basically I
have people who get paychecks in my
community. Okay. Comparatively to the
unemployed [__] of the end
community. But yeah,
like they the only reason why they
donate is because they probably are
living off of welfare and disability
checks. By the way, I advocate for
welfare and disability checks, okay? I
advocate for for these, okay? But you
know what? Using them on like JTK or
Quean instead of like actual food is
probably not a good idea. Okay? I think
that's a misuse of um government
allocated funds. All right.
>> Like a total [__] loser, but I'm sure
>> generally look at motorbikes on his
phone as he waits for the next game to
load.
>> You get the point.
>> Not a good idea. Like for of the
anti-fan community, but yeah,
>> looking like
>> like they the only reason why they
donate is because they probably are
living off of welfare and disability
checks. By the way, I advocate for
welfare and disability checks, okay? I
advocate for for these, okay? But you
know what? using them on like Jstelk or
Queman instead of like actual food is
probably not a good idea. Okay, I think
that's a misuse of um government
allocation.
>> Guys, if you are on EBT, donate to me
right now. If you receive EBT, donate to
me right [__] now. I need that US
government money. Where else is it going
to? Killing kids. Just send send me your
EBT right now. Okay. Poor US chatters.
Yeah. Gamma. A gamma. A gamma. No. Gamma
just spent all his money on a Mustang.
I'm hearing. I'm hearing Gamma just
spent all of his money on a Mustang. His
life savings on a Mustang. He's gone
into debt for a Mustang. If you're on
PIP in the UK, if you're on PIP, send me
money.
>> Like a total [__] loser. But I'm sure
you get the point. I doubt Dev will ever
respond substantially to any criticism,
let alone mine. And ultimately, I think
that's fine. It probably
>> Don't say you don't have any funs. It's
the start of the month. It's the start
of the month. You just got there.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Oh, he's live streaming right now.
>> Yo, thank you source of awesome. Thank
you for the 10 gifted. Hugely
appreciated. Thanks so much.
Thank you, Jimly, for the $50. I can't
believe the government gave me this
money just because I said I was Somali.
Thank you. Hugely appreciated, Jimly and
Source of awesome. Hugely appreciated.
Thank you guys. And I see with the five
gifted. Thank you so much. Hugely
appreciated. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Oh, okay. But like as as I was
saying, like dude, what like why the
[__] should Dev ever give like even an
ounce of attention towards these bad
faith malicious liars? Like you can tell
they're absolutely scrambling like
chomping at the bits for any kind of
relevancy, right? Because they know that
they have like a
>> yo, thank you Gucci for the €10. Thank
you, Crimson Desert Fund. That will that
that will not be going in the Crimson
Desert.
>> I can't believe that gave me this money
just because I said I was Somali.
>> Limited time on this platform, right?
Like maybe I don't have like maybe I
don't have unlimited time either, right?
which is why like I took a hiatus is
because I knew my time was up.
>> Jake Chinatown is um he's like he's the
guy who Ethan hates for retweeting a
post where someone said um I want to
repeatedly slam Bruce Klein into an oak
tree or some [__] like that. I I I'd
love to swing Bruce Klein by his legs
and repeatedly slam it into an oak tree
or something to this effect. talking
about Ethan's kids basically wanting to
slam him into an oak tree and Ethan
hates him cuz that guy retweeted it.
Thank you mirror for the 50 Danish
croner. Huge appreciate. Thank you so
much and Hickory with the $5. Thank you.
That's so that's Shake Chinatown. He's
like he's one of the lefty orbit type
accounts
>> up during the time. But like like that's
why like I went and did mail work,
right? Instead of streaming and like put
my channel into hibernation mode, right?
Because because I knew because I knew
that like well, you know, when my time
is up, my time is up. I'm not going to
fight it. You know,
>> I am on welfare, but I can live off Cup
ramen as Duno with the kids are going to
eat Elmau. Rip those bozos.
>> Oh, hey. Thank you. Thank you so much
for the
>> Thank you for the£10. Wait, thank you.
Thank you.
>> An Australian. Wait, are you actually on
welfare? Damn, dude. I thought you were
uh Wait, I thought you worked. Oh,
Australian Australia does have a really
good welfare system, though. Like, to be
fair, like Australia is just cheating.
I'm pretty sure the welfare system. No,
I'm desert.
>> Not really. Okay. I don't think you're
regarded. I think I think even
>> I don't even like food in our community,
but yeah.
>> Smile.
>> Just liberated this money from my
starving polycule. Told them it's
>> can't tell when they're done. It's so
hard to tell when they're done. Thank
you. Thank you guys. Thank you. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Wait, but you
still receive welfare. Australia does
that. Like they don't. They like
employed welfare is a thing for them.
>> Oh, so now Food Shops is talking to her
chatters about their welfare.
>> I'll rip those bozos.
>> Like, well, you know, when my time is
up, my time is up. I'm not going to
fight it. You know,
>> I am on welfare, but I can live off Cup
ramen as Duno with the kids are going to
eat Elmau. Rip those bozos.
>> Oh, hey. Thank you. Thank you so much
for the tennis. Wait, are you actually
on welfare,
>> dude?
>> Damn, dude. I thought you were uh Wait,
I thought you worked.
>> Oh, Australian. Australia does have a
really good welfare system, though.
Like, to be fair. Like, Australia is
just cheating. I'm pretty sure the
welfare system. No, I'm regarded. Oh,
okay. Dude, food shops is like, yeah,
see, look, my chat has come out and
donate and prove that prove that they've
got jobs, they touch grass, they've got
wives, they've got kids, they get hoes,
they're out there doing [__] Then the
dono's like donuts again and says, "No,
I actually I'm I'm on welfare. I'm on
welfare, but I can live off Cup ramen.
Don't know what the kids are going to
eat, though." And and food shop says,
"Wait, really? You're on you're on
welfare?" Like, yeah, I I'm [__]
I'm [__] I get disability. Great
job, FA. Really great job here. Really
great. Really owned the haters. DG
strong. We are here, Steven. I can't do
the Indian voice. S
Steven Steven. S. We are here. We are
here. Steven, come to India, Steven.
Come to India. I'm Indian Godston. I am
Indian. [__] We are here. Steven.
>> Not really. Okay. I don't think you're
regarded. I think I think you've been
consistently a pretty smart person in
our community. But you know, I work Oh,
okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Wait, but you
still receive welfare. Australia does
that. Like they don't they like employed
welfare is a thing for them. Pretty
wild. Okay. I do want to see I I do want
to see what um I do want to see what
Brown is up to. Okay. Today. All right.
No, I'm lying about welfare. Oh, okay.
Okay. Okay. Gotcha. Bro, dude, I I don't
know. Like I I wouldn't judge you if you
were on welfare. Okay. Like I I still
wouldn't judge you. I'm I'm not getting
>> Okay. They were pretending to be on
welfare. They were pretending to be on
welfare. Okay. Okay. Now they're like,
"Okay, I'mma shut up." All right.
>> Yeah. Okay.
Said one.
>> Yeah. For real. For real. I would I
wouldn't judge you for being on welfare
after literally two seconds ago jud
judging people for being on welfare. Uh
no, you should judge people for being on
welfare though. You should do that.
That's good. Actually, you should kind
of judge people for that.
>> It was Rob.
>> People are telling him to. Um and I'm
not trying. He will say Pixie is an evil
succub.
>> Like like this guy this guy is 100% like
my number one like crush hav. Okay. Like
I don't think like again I don't think
I've ever met I don't think I've ever
met anyone who is so like spiteful over
like me not reciprocating feelings.
Okay. Like again, I'm pretty sure I have
showed like DMs. I'm pretty sure I
showed DMs of like Moral like trying to
hit on me in private. Like it's so
embarrassing. It's so embarrassing. And
just a reminder, okay, when he like says
all these things about me, he was okay
with it. He was okay with it when he was
hitting on me, okay? Because love do
things, okay? Love makes you do things,
okay? It's a tough world out there,
okay? Like it's tough. I'm telling you.
Oh, okay. All right. So, I'm just gonna
show this again. Okay. Because [__] it.
Okay. Here. This for the editor
specifically. So, Mal says, "So, if I
started like really sexually harassing
you or whatever, would you le DMs? This
is important to know going forward. Just
asking really broad questions. So, I
said immediately. Well, as long as you
understand I'm genuinely a lesbian,
lol." And then says, "Fuck. God damn it.
>> What's going on, man?"
>> Oh, God. It was so embarrassing, bro.
Like, it's just like, how do you live
with, bro? Like, he's been hanging on to
this for like how many months at this
point? Like, bro,
>> wow, great stuff.
>> That is a Also, also for people, right?
Okay. So, also for people who's saying,
"Oh, well, don't you know he's doing
this exaggerated sarcasm?" Sure, he is,
but it's only to hide his real feelings.
Okay. Like, it's not like he's doing
this exaggerated sarcasm for nothing,
right? Like if I ever mess up an
interaction with a girl, like obviously
I would also do this exaggerated
sarcasm, right? Like I'll be like,
>> right, like in order to like indicate
that I'm kind of like self-aware of
myself in order to ease up the scenario,
right? Like it's very clear to me. It's
very clear to me that like,
>> right, he's like a showjo tag.
>> He actually was into me. Like otherwise,
why would he say, "Oh, if I want to
sexually harass you, right?" But it's
just that he wanted to play it off,
right? Gester maxing. Exactly right.
Yeah. So, so that because because that's
also an excuse that Mal goes to. Mal
would often times say, "Well, don't you
know that was for the sake of humor?
Don't you know that was for the sake?"
>> No, that's not what people saying, Ral.
Actually, I don't think that's what
people I don't think that's being said
>> because you wanted to make it less
awkward. That's why you did that because
that was a genuine Because that was a
genuine obviously to anybody that was a
genuine like like hitting on me, but you
just wanted to play it off. I
understand. Okay. Because like
essentially what Dev does is he's just
taking Desty's side, right? That's what
he's doing. He just takes sides.
>> Oh, and of course and of course Jay
Stuck goes over it. Of course, how could
he not? I mean, it's just free content
by his own community.
>> He takes Destiny's side. And then when I
say, "Hey, how is she using it in bad
faith?"
>> He knows his only argument is going to
be, "Well, given Destiny's
interpretation, I think this is really
bad." Right? Like like for example, if I
if I said to Mal that I was actually
into him back, like do you think he
would say no? Ponder that question in
your mind. I'm serious. Ponder that
question in your mind. Okay. Do you
think that if I didn't reject his
advances, like do you think he would say
no to like dating me or e dating me or
something? Ask yourself that question.
Okay, just do it.
>> Maybe maybe he's got like now that it's
months. Well, it's like a joke character
for this like that three layers deep. I
think
>> maybe. But when he said it, he
absolutely didn't.
>> Bro, I skipped to a random timestamp. Is
he talking about himself? Because like
what is the chances of him just
happening to mention this is what he
does
>> cuz I know multiple people multiple
people in private and he couldn't
substantiate anything he was saying. He
was just taking a side, right?
>> I was just pretending to be [__]
guys. I was just pretending to be into
gawk. Guys,
>> I think it has gotten chippy in filings.
For a record, it's like really sad to
see in a way because like these people
are clearly like like very like they
hate themselves, right? Like it's very
clear to me they hate themselves for
having an attraction towards like um uh
for for having an attraction towards um
I don't know like towards towards trans
women, right? Like am I the only one who
sees that? Like they're they just hate
themselves for it which is why they have
to make fun of other people for it. But
then it's such a sad way to live, right?
>> So maybe you have like some kind of an
argument, but he certainly didn't back
then.
>> Poor but will never explain himself.
This results in Dev constantly virtue
signaling, doing performative activism
and running.
>> I think you've got
>> So can you imagine
>> I I can't say what you've got to do
after this moral
>> like trying to get like J Stokes
validation.
>> I think there's only one way to get your
dignity back
by making videos so then he can watch it
on his term. Like what a pathetic sad
life to live, right? Like you should
just like go off and go to college. Like
at least I completed college, right? But
this is just like really sad.
>> Constantly from debates all while
criticizing Hassan for doing the same
exact thing. What if I
>> Okay, you know, you could you can do the
whole at least I completed college
thing. You're actually smarter than a
person. Now moral gets treated like a
total [__] Um, but he is
significantly smarter than food shops
and can actually string like a coherent
thought together and express it without
like breaking down into Chinese
nonsense. So, I really don't think that
counts for much. I really don't think
that counts for much.
>> Told you Dev actually had a pattern of
lying though. And this wasn't just the
one instance with Assan. Let's start
small. Someone asks Dev if he's okay
with pedophiles in his community. Dev
says, "No, that's why I banned you." In
contrast, here's a clip of Dev saying he
feels bad about banning pedophiles in
his community as long as they're not
preying on children in his Discord.
>> If I knew for sure that someone on my
server was trying to ddle kids, then I'd
ban them like 100%.
>> I don't think those are feathers. I
think those are feed.
>> Hey Dev, what's up?
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Test test test.
>> Hey, what's up?
>> A little out loud here.
>> Like if none of it was happening in your
spaces.
>> I don't know. It feels It feels wrong to
me. On Twitter, I make a reference to
Lilith Love it being a fan of Shadman.
Dev criticizes me for saying I came
without evidence. This is funny
considering he had no evidence for the
Assan shooter thing. But sure, let me
substantiate my claim unlike you. In
2018, Lilith Love it did a cosplay of
Shadman. This was after Shadman
sexualized real children with Daphne
Keen, Keemstar's daughter, and
Lieutenant Corbus.
>> Uh-oh. Uh-oh. You guys remember a couple
nights ago where I told you that Dev was
retweeting people at 3:00 a.m. instead
of responding to me? You remember that?
I I recognize this name. I recognize
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I think I
>> Bro, he he he even has like the [__]
Queenman laugh, bro. Okay, for anybody
who has had
>> That's not how I laugh. That's not how I
laugh.
>> The like displeasure of watching a
Queenman video. Like even Quan Quman
kind of laughs like this like like he
kind He kind of laughs in this manner.
So like they all like it's funny that
they call everybody else skinwalkers of
destiny when they literally skinwalk
their number one role model anyway. So
like skinwalker versus skinwalker
competition type right but when it comes
to the substance like
>> I don't make faces like
>> all right that's it that's enough that's
enough that's 10 minutes.
>> Okay I can't
>> that's actually the queue has gone too
far too far this one time.